I'm Rasheed with the latest there let's
bring you some breaking news Nigel Adams
the MP for Selby and HD has resigned as
an MP he's uh formally resigned this
afternoon of course he was one of the
MPS that was rumored to be put forward
for a resignation period by the former
prime minister Boris Johnson but he
wasn't on the final list according to
the Prime Minister who then passed that
list on to the committee that decides on
peerages he was on there along well he
was meant to be on there along with a
few other names that didn't make that
final cut a lot of controversy about
that this afternoon as to the names put
forward and who was approved who was not
and who and was and wasn't on the list
but Nigel Adams has formally resigned as
an MP this afternoon when asked whether
also we understand that the prime
minister's official spokesman said the
Prime Minister was clear he's not going
to deviate from established a convention
that is why he forwarded the list this
is as part of the ongoing rail Boris
Johnson allerging that the prime
minister is talking rubbish when he says
that Boris Johnson asked the prime
minister to do something he didn't want
to do which was to override a
committee's decision on peerages